le bob bell média comme un bon d'après
les écrits passés me aventure pas moyen
de 6 vraiment l'histoire a lui même les
paradigmes connaissance mais millions
l'instrument le bas mais me sortent en
afrique un ami proche de larry la
réunion avec le peuplement
le beau brun est un instrument de
musique à cordes frappées
c'est un arc musical cousin dubé ringo
utilisée au brésil pour rythmer la
capoeira un art martial afro-brésilien
l'instrument tire son origine du
continent africain il est arrivé à la
réunion avec les premiers esclaves qui
peut l'utiliser pour le maloya mont
faron côté me travaillait pas vraiment l
art l'insee monbaron côté me travaille
là c'est tout et l'opa tsimi stocks non
peut paraît la simple flux à cannes m'a
ramassé cette année pour les
travailleurs
jean-luc habite à l'étang saint-leu
passionné de maloya il s'est lancé dans
la fabrication d'instruments
traditionnels il ya maintenant 20 ans
ils fabriquent aussi de bonnes le fait
muter dans le marianne avait 5 20
seulement il y avait le rouleur le
kayamb le pic est le sat il avait le bob
donc en fin de compte mais bon on a fait
les particuliers ni ne la fais les
gaillards les sons qui moi me mca qui
les en a fait un peu ne valait pas dire
les mystique mais hanafi les comme si
coulé dans des coins affaires sont
l'écriture c'est légal
le double est donc un arc musical
il est composé de trois parties
essentielle donc le bob l'écopôle est
composé d'un réseau nature c'est la
calebasse et ça les mains tenu qu'à un
fil cuiv après on est malade c'est le
sait le bout de bois là et on en a un
fils de fer quitte si halak apprennent à
le baguette
ban appelle ça le bat avec les pas malin
vendre le noie les comas et maintenant
ça va donner à peine à écarter la
matière c'est que jus de la matière
naturelle au fond contre
mis à part le fil de fer le son du globe
et varient sulu ses composants à savoir
la taille de la calebasse mais aussi la
tension est de type de cordes utilisées
mais ce qui fait par dessus tout un bob
et c'est selon yvan la parfaite osmose
avec le musicien
à moins de mettre en attente d'un box et
quand michel il a défait monde
fournissons somalie les dames
l'inspiration pour mettre mettre des
mots dessus et enfin s'ils m'appellent
l'inspiration la cie commis je vais
aller me sens pas rien mon panier dit
pas moins fait ça comme ça fait
sacrément de montech moi pas rien et ça
pour moi le bob les parlers pas les pas
beaux
le beau brun est un instrument ancestral
peu utilisé mais qui trouve encore toute
sa place dans la musique traditionnelle
et même moderne
l'instrument il a évolué de façon quand
midi l1 seulement les combats pliez vos
lui est pas totalement disparaître